exercises from Sara
Yoko okay Yoko a sideways moving
exercise just like I was going to take a
normal Chico step my leg's going to come
up but it's going to go out to the side
like this so normally I'd be moving
forward with my shico step but this time
I'm going to move over to the side from
here I'm going to plant my knee as I
pull myself over here and pull myself
over as you're doing this it's important
to try not to slam this knee down so on
a mat it would be so bad if you're on a
hardwood floor this would be very very
painful if you slam your knee down so as
I come down I try not to go and hit my
knee really hard against the ground
instead I curve my knee as it comes down
this lessens the impact that will happen
with that
knee sideways move is really useful
you'll use it a lot when you're
practicing s WIA techniques your
cool